leute ich habe etwas entdeckt dass ich
euch zeigen möchte aber erst mal
herzlich willkommen hier in meinem
freiluft büro hier trifft man mich
eigentlich immer an wenn ich gerade
nicht filme und nicht bei den tieren
oder im garten bin ich habe gerade hier
diese speicherkarte durchforstet aus
einem ganz anderen grund und da haben
nicht zufällig über bilder gestolpert
von unserem jetzigen selbstversorger
küchengarten aber bevor wir den angelegt
haben wir wurden ja seit etwas über
einem jahr hier
das heißt er ist noch gar nicht so alt
es ist noch überhaupt nicht lange her
dass wir hier unseren neuen garten
angelegt haben
aber die veränderung zu sehen wie sich
dieses grundstück entwickelt hat war
wirklich enorm und deswegen bin ich
gerade ganz motiviert euch ein video
zusammenzuschneiden in dem ihr sieht wie
wir den garten angelegt haben mit was
für herausforderungen wir zu kämpfen
hatten und wie der jetzt aussieht das
ist ein garten der uns als familie wir
sind drei personen komplett mit gemüse
versorgt wir haben noch ein acker wo wir
unsere kartoffeln und kürbisse und auch
zwiebeln und karotten anbauen alles
andere wächst aber hier und ich denke es
ist sehr schön für uns alle mal
mitzuerleben wie sich das alles
entwickelt hat und wieso ein
selbstversorger garten entsteht also
ganz viel spaß mit dem video ja hier
seht ihr das grundstück wie es aussah
bevor wir unseren gärten angelegt haben
da stand eine alte gartenhütte da war
noch viel mehr bäume und sträucher die
jetzt auf dem foto schon gar nicht mehr
drauf sind deren wurzeln aber noch in
der erde sind oder gewesen sind und an
vielen stellen waren ebenso betonsteine
in den boden eingelassen wir haben dann
ganz vielen stellen nichts anderes mehr
vorgefunden hat seine art sandkasten auf
dem vorher steine gelegen haben für eine
terrasse wo dann 30 zentimeter dicken
sand auf dem boden aufgeschichtet war
und der boden auch so buck verdichtet
war mein sohn hat sich natürlich gefreut
darüber ich nicht so sehr die pflanzen
auch nicht denn in den sandkasten kann
man kein gemüse an
aber zum glück haben wir schon reichlich
erfahrung gesammelt wie es ist in
der schwierigen verhältnissen zu werden
und deswegen mussten wir auch schon dass
die compass beete die wir super gerne
anlegen für diesen garten genau das
richtige sind ja dann haben wir unsere
kompass beete angelegt es war ungefähr
im mai also relativ spät im jahr ende
mai war der garten dann fertig aber das
ist ja eine zeit in der leben- gemüse
eigentlich alle schon in der erde sind
so dass wir uns dann wirklich spüren
muss das wieder aufzuholen ich habe dann
ganz viel gesät und gepflanzt wie die
saatgut tütchen geschnappt und gegeben
und was das zeug hält ganz vieles
ländchen vorgezogen
und ja es ist jedes jahr aufs neue so
ein wunder zu sehen wie aus einer
handvoll samen und garten wächst und wie
alles anfing zu sprießen und zu grünen
und zu gedeihen das war super super
befriedigen die ersten monats zu zu
erleben ich zeige euch mal unseren
garten als sehr ungefähr
ich habe da war ja so zwei drei monate
alt da sah der garten schon so aus als
er schon ende diesen unterschied zu dem
grundstück wie es vorher ausgesehen hat
und das jetzt noch mal zu sehen das
macht mich so stolz gerade ich bin
einfach super happy und dann ja auch die
erste ernte einzufahren
das ist einfach ein ganz tolles gefühl
dass man nur nachvollziehen kann wenn
man selber auch geordnet haben dann im
sommer ein gewächshaus aufgebaut ein
viktorianisches gewächshaus von dem ich
schon ewig lange geträumt habe und das
hilft uns enorm das ganze jahr über zu
gärtnern im sommer wie winter im sommer
stehen da unsere tomaten und sind super
gut geschützt vor wind und wetter im
winter können wir im dem gewächshaus
immer noch eine riesengroße palette von
gemüse selber aus unserem eigenen garten
ernten was natürlich wenn man versucht
das ganze jahr aus dem garten zu essen
super super wichtig ist aber und das ist
etwas was mir wirklich sehr am herzen
liegt ich will
die selbstversorgung so fantastisch ist
auch ist sich selbst zu versorgen
ich will das nicht romantisieren hier
auf diesem kanal
denn selbstversorgung ist richtig harte
arbeit und ich glaube das geht oft ein
bisschen unter hier auf youtube wenn man
sich die ganzen schönen videos anschaut
natürlich will ich niemanden entmutigen
selber das eigene essen anzubauen sich
ein stück weit selbst zu versorgen oder
vielleicht zu versuchen möglichst viel
selber anzubauen
aber man muss wissen das ist schon sehr
sehr viel arbeit und auch erfahrung
braucht um das wirklich richtig hilfe
kriegen wir haben zum beispiel dieses
jahr drei mal unsere gemüse vorgezogen
und gepflanzt und jedes mal sind wieder
die bühne unserer nachbarn gekommen und
haben alles abgefressen und wenn ihr
kratzt weggeschaut so dass keine einzige
pflanze übrig war und nicht nur mit den
jungs an sondern auch mit größe und
pflanzen und überwintert haben und das
war super frustrierend dass es jetzt nur
ein beispiel von tausend sachen sich
nicht leben können und die auch schief
gehen werden
denn wir haben jedes jahr solche mehr
oder weniger großen katastrophen in
unserer selbstversorgung aber ich will
dir sagen wenn du solche sachen er liebt
oder wenn es vielleicht schnecken sind
die dir alles wegfressen die innerhalb
kürzester zeit über deinen garten
herfallen und die bleibt nichts übrig
als ohne schleimige spur die dir noch
verrät wer der übeltäter aber ich weiß
genau wie frustrierend das ist und ich
weiß auch wie wichtig es ist trotzdem
weiterzumachen und sich nicht entmutigen
zu lassen es gibt ja dieses sprichwort
das heißt glaube ich einen garten zu
pflanzen bedeutet an die zukunft zu
glauben und an manchen stellen in
unserem selbstversorger leben nun
selbstversorger erfahrungen ist es mir
extrem schwer gefallen mich wieder
aufzuraffen und zu sagen ich glaube
daran dass es noch mal funktioniert auch
wenn es schon drei mal schief gegangen
ist sehe ich jetzt noch mal alle meine
gemüse aus und werde die wieder in
diesem garten pflanzen in der hoffnung
dass sie diesmal unversehrt bleiben und
wachsen können und es ist manchmal
superhart das zu machen
und sich in den hintern zu treten und zu
sagen lass dich davon nicht entmutigen
du machst jetzt weiter aber es ist es so
was von wert wenn man dann sieht es hat
geklappt unser garten ist jetzt
natürlich um einige wochen hinterher als
ich ihn eigentlich haben wollte aber es
hat geklappt es wächst gemüse in unserem
garten ich bin wieder zufrieden und
gerade auch wenn du tiere hältst gibt es
so viel was schiefgehen kann
wir haben letztes jahr als witzige klein
bekommen haben hatten wir eine ziege die
ihre kleinen nicht angenommen hat und
das war herzzerreißend zu sehen wie
diese kleinen frisch geborenen ziehen
die keine stunde alt waren versucht habe
man hier zu trinken und sie hat sie
einfach nur weggeboxt und dass eine
sogar versucht zu töten
wir haben die dann mit der flasche
aufgezogen das ist natürlich unglaublich
niedlich so kleine süße tiere bei sich
zu hause zu haben aber es hat mir doch
so wehgetan zu wissen dass sie
eigentlich bei ihrer mutter sein sollten
und dadurch dass sie so menschen bezogen
waren hatten wir auch sehr große
probleme
die ziemlich ziemlich fatale folgen
hatte nämlich waren diese menschen
bezogen dass sie jedes mal wenn leute an
der weide vorbeigelaufen sind in den
zaun gesprungen sind weil sie unbedingt
zu den menschen wollten weil sie dachten
das ist meine ich will dahin das ist
meine familie
und eines tages kam ich dahin und der
kleine box ist er mit dem weißen pohlig
mit dem baum hing stranguliert im zaun
und sowas bricht ein wirklich das herz
also das sind ja auch tiere die einem
super ganz herz wachsen und trotzdem
gehört es dazu es sind immer wieder
tiere bei uns gestorben und das ist
etwas womit man irgendwann dann
irgendwie leben lernt
und gerade mit den tieren hat man immer
wieder ärger
gerade mit ziegen er so wenn du dir
irgendwelche tiere zur selbstversorgung
anschaffen willst dann überleg dir
dreimal ob es wirklich zu sein müssen
ich habe die nur weil ich den leider
total verfallen bin weil ich sie
unglaublich art liebe und ja wie gesagt
ich hab seit 14 jahren ziegen ich kann
nicht mehr anders er war bevor du damit
anfängst überleg dir das lieber dreimal
[Musik]
aber trotzdem ist es so erfüllt sich
selbst zu versorgen und es ist so ein
schönes gefühl wenn du deine pflanzen
hegt und pflegt und sie ist wie sie
wachsen und gedeihen und so eine enge
verbindung zu den tieren hast und dann
deiner familie die erste ernte auf tisch
wenn du dann merkst du jetzt habe ich so
viel
er hatte aus meinem garten dass ich das
für den winter haltbar machen kann dass
ich da meinen eigenen kleinen
wintervorrat anlegen kann
ganz viele schätze haltbar machen kann
aus meinem eigenen garten und es ist ein
superschönes tolles gefühl und es gibt
einem so einen befriedigenden rhythmus
über das ganze jahr wo immer wieder die
gleichen dinge anstehen und man super
abhängig von den jahreszeiten ist aber
eben auch super davon geprägt wird dann
im herbst die zeit ist um die samen zu
ehren von dem gemüse dass man selber
angebaut hat man seine eigenen worten
weiter vermehrt jahr für jahr und
weiterentwickelt an den eigenen garten
anpasst und meinem sohn zu vermitteln
dass es super wichtig und wertvoll ist
mit der natur zu arbeiten statt gegen
die natur das ist ein geschenk was ich
jedem kind wünsche und wo ich
unglaublich froh bin dass ich das meinem
sohn ermöglichen kann so aufzuwachsen
[Musik]
ich glaube drei parteien schließlich
muss welche sich aus dem eigenen garten
selbst zu versorgen gibt dein leben
einfach einen wunderschönen rhythmus du
hast den winter in dem kaum arbeit
anfällt und dem du dich ausruhen kannst
und träumen kannst von deinen neuen
garten neben irgendwann die saatgut
kataloge ankommen wenn du deine saatgut
tütchen ordnung ist und dein garten
planst meine ganzen großen wilden träume
aufzeichnet und dem garten den du im
sommer haben möchtest dann die zeit im
frühling wenn super viel zu tun ist weil
die ganzen pläne umsetzen möchten die
gemüse in die erde franzen möchtest und
sehr ist was das zeug hält wenn dann die
erste ernte ansteht und am sommer der
ein kochtopf quasi rund um die uhr läuft
weil du gar nicht mehr weiß wohin mit
dem ganzen obst und gemüse und du
manchmal auch ein bisschen demut
verlierst wenn vielleicht sachen nicht
so gut laufen wie sie sollten aber dann
wieder an fahrt gewinnt wenn du merkst
wie viel ernte den garten abwirft und
dass ich das ja schon wieder dem ende
neigt dass die pause wieder in sicht ist
die man dann auch braucht im winter es
ist ja nicht so dass im winter nichts
anbauen aber man hat viel viel weniger
zu tun im winter und das tut auch gut
das ist auch wichtig damit man sich im
frühling dann wieder auf das neue
gartenjahr freuen kann und was
vielleicht am schönsten ist ist das egal
was für fehler du dieses jahr macht egal
wie fatal die sind und was alles schief
läuft bekommst jedes jahr eine komplett
neue chance es ist komplett egal was du
dieses jahr alles falsch gemacht hast im
frühling kannst du noch mal komplett von
vorne anfangen
das kannst du jedes jahr machen du wirst
jedes jahr aus seinen fehlern lernen und
du hast jedes jahr die chance dieses
jahr zu deinem besten garten ja wie
überhaupt zu machen
[Musik]